it sounds like then you're building a
mini rapport with everyone you come in
contact but there's craft services or
hair and makeup yeah yeah I think it's
that and I I think it's that I have a
strong desire to make sure that that
they know they're appreciated for what
they do know what I'm know you know what
am i I'm you know I'm a character actor
showing up as a guest but they're in
there supporting what I do in a tangible
and intangible way so if I can let them
know my god that was a nice meal you
know I I really appreciate that because
we moved through so fast you know things
are happening so fast on the set time is
money and I have I have such great
regard for the people who do it and
supported those crews you know what I
did I had an interesting experience when
I did Grey's Anatomy because I was badly
damaged their character was badly
damaged I should say but you know that
and they they all left me alone you know
there was a there was that thousand yard
stare that you get into and they knew
that I had to go back in but every once
in a while a grip would walk by and just
put his hand on my shoulder if you know
my god
to have that kind of care or camaraderie
or just as someone say I'm with you you
know I know this is painful what you're
doing
I appreciate it you know they can have
any award they want I don't know that
anyone's ever gonna feel better
at that moment of having something one
of your colleagues one of the guys
that's you know humping who knows how
much cable or lighter or trying to make
you look good just put a hand on your
shoulder that way you know I'll be
forever grateful for that and I do think
you know as a and for young actors going
in you just need to try to find a space
that you can work in you know some some
people are open to you gosh you know
when I first came out here Kathy Baker
came up to me and welcomed me to her
said thank you so much for joining us
old school they used to see that a lot
Mark Harmon Hale Harmon brought me
coffee
he's number one on the call sheet and
he's never know one another and and and
I'm proud to be able to call Martin my
friend but he's number one on the call
sheet he's bringing me okay walking
across the lot to bring me a cup of
coffee that's old school you're not
gonna see that as much as in the old
days but you can still you know you can
just extend yourself and if it's not
reciprocated it's not about you they're
thinking about something they're working
on something or they're you know there's
a lot of pathology in our business you
know we all have always said if you got
to be 40 feet tall on screen to be seen
here's pathology and play the present
company included so you know let them
have what they need and if they can't
reciprocate then keep your palms open
and do your job
you